if you give an opinion other people
don't like there's no conversation about
it anymore it's like you're bad for this
reason and we want to ruin your life and
get and cancel you I'm shocked mostly by
who is trying to do that I've you know
that it's it's scary to me that there
are certain elements of the DNC or the
Democratic Party that is attacking the
people that are its base right the
people that will actually go and knock
on doors and change an election it's the
strategy of attacking Bernie over the
last four months I just don't understand
it why why would you attack one of your
strongest candidates and all his
followers are looking at it like well
you guys are doing the same thing you
did last time and you haven't learned
your lesson I just don't understand the
strategy it seems like they want a
candidate who they think is guaranteed
to beat Trump which is what they thought
they had last time and if anybody is a
little more radical or different
thinking they're worried that the middle
isn't gonna like them so let's destroy
them now how many times does an expert
how many times isn't an expert allowed
to be wrong before they're not right
spirt anymore right and this seems to
happen just every time it's just you
knew that who we're listening to while
we were listening to these same people
that screwed it up last time I just
don't get it
I'm offer a change you know however
whatever it takes but it just seems to
me what's stupid to attack your base did
Bernie have another choice too because
when he when they found out that they
were screwing him I guess Wasserman
Schultz and they were screwing him in
the last time and then he kind of lined
up and supported Hillary just cuz they
wanted to be Trump do you think there
was another alternative for him at that
time I don't know if he could have done
anything I was almost like why did he
just get in line behind her when he was
more interesting than she was and I
think he would have done better in the
debates than she did I think he realized
that she was better than Trump but
here's the thing he went out and stumped
for her when all over the place for her
and now her supporters in that wing of
the DNC is saying that he never did that
as it had never happened which is even
weirder for me it's like why don't you
accept the reality and since we're by
the way I'm doing 1984 in Los Angeles
[Laughter]
you know the concept of doublespeak you
know holding two contradictory thoughts
in your head at the same time being able
to go to either one whatever is
convenient yeah yeah you know it's it's
it's it's crazy to me I I would love to
see it stop because you know it's not
going to be an effective strategy and
turning out people I think the only way
we're going to beat Trump is if there's
a massive voter turnout do you get do
you get nervous when things get weirdly
cyclical again and you're like wait is
this we doing the same thing well you
know during that when when I came out
against the Iraq war I I and people like
me were called traitors and you know
against you know we were we were dummies
we were dupes you know Saddam lovers all
that stuff doesn't matter what that we
were right doesn't you don't get any
prizes for that later on no you know we
don't really talk about that anymore
yeah and you know it's just saying I
think that tbh just wrote this piece in
Rolling Stone about this about Tulsi
Gabbard and Hillary Clinton all this
things like you do the same kind of
strategy is like anyone that disagrees
with us is Putin dupe right yeah anyone
that disagrees with us is a traitor it's
dumb it's it's ill-advised
it alienates people I don't understand
their strategy I just don't get it I'm
so glad you said that I literally
started the show this morning with both
of us trying to figure out what could
possibly be the move here what's there
obviously there is a strategy what the
hell is going on I said we should asked
him when he gets in because he seems
up-to-date on this yeah and you're
coming in no idea one more Jim and Sam
catch up with full episodes and
interviews from celebrity guests anytime
on demand using the Sirius XM adage